hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast comprehensive variation
at clinical population scales will
Salerno from the human genome sequencing
center at Baylor College of Medicine
will be the speaker for this event we
are excited to bring you this
educational webinar presented by labrys
the leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars for advancing scientific
collaboration learning this webinar
sponsored by DNAnexus the leader in
cloud-based biomedical informatics and
data management DNAnexus enables the
advancement of biomedical discovery
through the sharing of tools and
datasets in a secure compliant and
collaborative ecosystem our work
accelerates scientific insights in the
healthcare and research space to solve
the largest challenges in the market
today I am John dedi and a principal
scientist at DNAnexus
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this is an event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the Q&A
button located in the bottom of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem and now I'd
like to introduce today's speaker will
Salerno director of genome informatics
at the human genome sequencing center
who will share his experience and
insight developing a scalable
informatics model for at scale WGS
please join me in welcoming will Salerno
I will now turn the presentation over to
him great thanks John and thanks
everyone for joining today really glad
to have the opportunity to speak and
about comprehensive variation at
clinical population scales this is work
that we've been doing here in Houston at
the HGS Sea and with our partners all
over the world but especially at the UT
School of Public Health and for those
who might not be familiar with the human
genome sequencing center here in Houston
the we just celebrated our 20-year
anniversary we have a hundred 80 staff a
huge sequencing fleet of all kinds of
different platforms it's a long history
I've been at the sequencing center for
about six years but one of the big
advances we've made for the last couple
years is the launching of the HTS CCL
our Clinical Laboratory and everyone
should feel rest assured that it was it
was safe during Carvey last year I rode
my bike into the Medical Center and this
is the picture I took before I rode my
bike through that and that was a mistake
but we have survived and we continue to
push here in Houston with all of these
partners that we have here our vision
for bringing genomics into medicine and
really driving you know this idea of
personalized medicine so you know I run
the next-gen sequencing informatics
group we do all the data processing and
the informatics R&D for both the
research and the clinical sides so when
I think about how we drive
research and clinical research into
human disease with genomics I sort of
broke it down into this chart which is
by no means complete but it does sort of
lay out the different types of steps
that you can have when you're doing
genomics experiments that's relevant to
human health and disease and just to go
through sort of briefly you could see on
the left that if you start with DNA
sequencing you do whole exomes in a trio
you call your small small variants and
coding regions and you compare that to
traits of interest that's what coding
quote I'm calling you sort of Ben
Delian mod or maybe those traits are
rare diseases as you start to expand out
into cohorts which are the green lines
you're still using DNA sequencing maybe
it's EXO maybe it's genome maybe it's
chip but you're using multiple samples a
lot of times you still bring that back
to small variants in the coding regions
you compare with phenotypes and traits
and that's sort of the G wast model now
obviously none of these descriptions are
complete but the ideas that we're
progressing increasingly right and
filling out this graph you know really I
think where we are at right now the
human genome sequencing Center is a lot
of data being driven by our whole genome
sequencing program and large cohorts but
not limiting that analysis to small
variants and coding regions but also
looking at complex structural variation
I'm looking at non-coding and regulatory
regions and then not just thinking about
you know endpoint traits but also end of
phenotypes integrating longitudinal data
and doing a really robust genotype
phenotype analysis you know some of our
forward-looking work is really moving
that top row across from DNA into this
multi-omics space with the idea that we
really have many ways to navigate the
space of human genomic data with the
point being how do we drive these
different combinations of data and
experimental designs really into
clinical interpretation how do we make
personalized mount medicine relevant to
every individual you know this n of one
idea so that's sort of the bottle you
know how we how we navigate this space
the road to this type of clinical
population transitioning from these
research to this clinical population a
population of nf1 the road here has gone
through a bunch of acronyms all these
great programs that we work with through
the various NIH programs NHLBI NHGRI the
ni a some of you may be familiar I'm not
going to go through all of these in
detail but I do want to give an overview
of the type of data we're dealing with
the top med program you know there's
currently about 130,000 genomes and a
lot of cardiovascular related cohorts
with a with an eye toward generating
multi-omics data that's really
interesting the CCD
program the Centers for common disease
genomics this is currently about 55 to
60,000 whole genomes that were working
on right now multiple cohorts like top
med multiple sequencing centers with the
idea that we want to marry the
sequencing generation with the specific
disease research working with the charge
and a DSP the Alzheimer's disease
consortium slightly different types of
data profiles at different scales but
the ideas that were working on specific
diseases and really going after a well
curated collection of phenotypes one of
the big components and all of these
programs is going after multiple
ethnicities again this idea that we want
to make personalized medicine relevant
to every individual and that means you
know any ethnic background you know
where we're creating appropriate models
for specific subgroups those that's all
large research work the clinical work
you know a lot of that has been driven
especially by our involvement in the
emerge program which is a custom panel
of clinically actionable genes you know
we've sequence 15,000 the whole sets
about 25,000 and this is work done by
our clinical lab the HGS VCO where we're
doing clinical sign out and really
focusing on this idea of how do you
automate at a large scale the return of
results so we had these large-scale
research programs we had this you know
very successful emerge program where
we're doing our sign out and where this
culminated was you know over the in the
last several months we were awarded one
of the genome Center grants for the all
of us program which is you know go and
sign up online the goal is to sequence a
million samples over five years we're
doing this with our partners at a cider
at johns hopkins and this is whole
genome and a clinical in a clinical
setting with then you know validation of
actionable variants and return of
results so that's really you know how
all of these programs that we've worked
with have has taken us to the point and
it's not just us we work with so many
other sequencing centers and
collaborators that this is the road the
nih has sort of been on to get to
clinical populations and we're very
happy to be a part of that a bit
specific to our Houston history at the H
GSD in the UT School of Public Health
you know we're driving this through
comprehensive variation the idea that
again when we talk about making
personalized medicine relevant to every
individual it's not just about your age
or where you live or your ethnicity it's
also about what kind of variants do you
have you know we want to make sure
personalized medicine isn't just
relevant for people who have small
variants inside coding regions if you
have something complex or large and a
regulatory region or outside what an
exome or the panel might pick up
personalized medicine needs to be
relevant to those individuals as well so
as you can see I'm not going to go
through all of these small pictures but
a lot of this work especially on the
informatics and analysis side was done
in collaboration with our partners at
DNAnexus and it started with a Personal
Genome doing a high-quality personal
genome analyzing structural variation
using short and long reads extending
this into the Alzheimer's and you can
see that as we progress we go so from
one sample to hundreds of samples to
thousands to tens of thousands and you
know currently working with the top med
IRC group to do structural variant
calling on over a hundred thousand a
whole genomes which will be the largest
such set of its time and then you'll see
the last step there going to all of us
here one with that that number drops but
I really want to draw attention to this
that you know in the first year of all
of us here at the HCC we might only be
doing seven to ten thousand old genomes
but they are going to be in this
clinical environment and the important
takeaway here is that scale just isn't
about how many samples you do it's also
about how you do them so sure we've been
scaling to more and more research
samples you know over the last several
years but there's a different type of
scaling we're doing now that we're going
to be doing these in a catholic lee
environment and thinking about how we
take these all the way through these
samples all the way through to a
clinically actionable space so we have
sort of these different ways of scaling
and that sort of the history and sort of
pointing toward the future of what we're
working on and my role as director of
genome informatics what are the hats I
wear is thinking about how do we
harmonize all of these data you'll note
that on those previous slide
where I talked about these large
projects we're working with a lot of
sequencing centers and these data are
being generated over a large period of
time and we're bringing data together
from a lot of different sources so you
know we only have so much control over
the quality and the consistency of the
data and we do a lot to think about how
do we harmonize those data at scale and
my approach is sort of threefold or the
work that we've done here at the group
you know step one is to try to prevent
heterogeneity and I'll talk about some
of the mechanisms that we've used and
put out to the community to sort of
standardize models across the field you
only can do that to a certain extent you
have to be prepared to correct your
heterogeneity and adjust for batch
effects and deal with that because
they're always going to be there but
finally you want to embrace the
heterogeneity and recognize the
different experimental designs different
types of populations not every batch
effect necessarily needs to be removed
if that's somehow informative for the
type of specific analysis that you're
doing
let your analysis reflect the
heterogeneity of the data so I'm gonna
walk through a couple of examples how
we've dealt with this harmonization at
scale because this harmonization is
critical for really building the large
sample sets across the diverse not just
a diverse population in terms of data
and what the tools needed to do that are
so thinking about how do you prevent
heterogeneity some of the work we've
done in collaboration with the CC DG
program was create the NIH functionally
equivalent protocol this is employed by
the CCD G which is currently again
working on 60,000 whole genomes the top
med are C working on 130,000 plus the
ADSP program and then the all of us
program just a few weeks ago decided
that they'd be using this protocol this
was something developed again out of the
CCD G in collaboration with top med work
led really by the whole group by Rahall
and his team at university of a lawsuit
accused me in st. Louis really did a lot
of great work here and there's a paper
that came out pretty recently that you
could look up but the idea was to get a
standardized mechanism of taking a fast
queue all the way through to a cram file
on the 38 reference bringing sort of
whole genome programs in the NIH into
that 38 space and also doing so in a way
that minimized the file footprint
standardized quality score pinning and
provided some features that were
amenable to structural variant calling
so all of the big whole genome
sequencing programs are on this protocol
and it really makes a lot of the
downstream analyses a lot easier when
you know that everything was sort of
mapped and aligned the same way on the
same version these pipelines are sort of
publicly available if you go read the
paper you'll see that there are doctors
out there there are apps on all
different cloud-based providers
including DNAnexus and this protocol
it's fast efficient and you know if it's
definitely where the field is packed
right now for whole genome sequencing so
that's one way that needs worked to
standardize upfront different types of
processing and I'll also point out that
you know you can see here in this
results column that you know doing this
actually improved from a cost
perspective and from a science
perspective a lot of the processing so
it's not just standardization for the
sake of standardization its
standardization because we think we can
sort of improve the quality of the data
all around another mechanism by which
you know we try to standardize is by
using robust QC to always assess what's
going on and when we're operating it's
scale there's I think there's a tendency
when you want to do QC to downsample
things you know I'm looking at a hundred
thousand samples let me look at ten
thousand of them let me look at a
hundred of them let me down sample my
coverage so you end up doing these down
samples and you do your analysis because
they're timely or they're expensive and
then you know you sort of do the math
and you do the very careful thing to
make sure that when you scale up the
results you found at the downsampled
levels hold and that's a great model
we're always going to have to do that
however given how how many smart people
there are as they're working on fast
methods for various genomics tasks we
really should be considering how to do
our R and B at the scale you know how
can we go ahead and make a call set on a
large number or vary
look at it and say okay we actually need
to adjust some parameters and redo that
you know this idea that we can do our
research at our QC act scale is an
interesting proposition one of the tools
we've worked with at the HG SC one of
the ones developed here on the team is X
Atlas it's our small SMB an endo collar
it's rapidly retrain about it gets from
a cram to a G VCF in less than a quarter
for a 30x whole genome and you know
there's some data here that shows that
you know as you navigate the sort of
sensitivity specificity time trade-off
that you really can do very fast high
quality variant calling that allows you
to do this type of R&D its scale and
then working with Michael in a GL Nexus
our sorry DNA next is on the GL nexus
software which allows us to go from the
GBCs to a project level VCF for large
numbers of samples and you know relative
in less than a couple days of processing
time less than seven core hours per
sample there's lots of mechanisms we're
having a very rapid small variant color
allow us to iterate quickly and do the
type of R&D that's necessary at scale
one example of this is when we my team
was asked to assess what kind of
clinical what kind of base level
coverage is appropriate in a clinical
setting so here we needed to compare at
various base level coverages the ability
for variant caller to accurately assess
true known variants well you know the
the number of samples that we have with
high-quality truth set variance is much
smaller than the scale of things that we
are sequencing so what we did is we took
a couple runs of na12878 which has a
very high confidence variance set and we
took deep coverage replicates of these
down sampled them to over a hundred 50
different coverages over the whole
genome which gave us a nice spectrum of
base coverage across the variance of
interest and we plotted the ability of X
Atlas to recover those Barry
cause that all of these different based
coverages and you know we sort of see
that around 15x coverage you can
confidently call these types of snicks
the point here is not the whole exercise
of doing the clinical coverage that's
not really what this talk is about but
what I do want to point out is that we
were able to run 150 instances of X
Atlas and get these variant calls across
own genomes in about an hour because we
have you know we have a very fast
mechanism it's doing this type of
research at scales opening up the types
of questions you can ask because you
have very fast tools another thing that
was nice about X Atlas and the ability
to what run things at very flexible
manner is to adapt to new platforms you
know when we've compared the Novus seek
and the high seat we changed the
parameters of X atlas to sort of do a
pile up something equivalent to a Sam
tools and pile up where you're looking
at every base and every quality score in
every position but we did this in a very
fast manner that also results in a G VCF
which allows us to merge them and what
we saw is that when you start looking at
the pile ups in these whole genomes
pre-notice ticket receipt you can see a
bit of a difference between the TI T V
ratio which may be something we're still
looking into this that may be related to
how the two-color chemistry differs from
the four-color chemistry so again the
point here is not enough Nova speak
versus the high speed comparison it's
the fact that by having a really
flexible tool we're able to dig into the
type of innovation that drives you know
precision medicine and you know getting
the best technology of the clinic as
fast as possible
you know these types of analyses and
being able to tweak our variant caller
again another example here is looking at
the Quality Score effects on low allele
ratio variance you know a lot of these
variant colors are trained in a sort of
diploid manner they want to go after
things that are roughly a 50% allele
ratio unless you have you know a somatic
collar which is looking at a different
setting but you know you might want to
be calling things that are less
confident in a germline setting where
you're expecting a 50% ratio but because
it might have clinical relevance you
might want to be a bit more sensitive
one of the things that we know
is that depending on how your quality
scores are bend in some of these
scenarios you can see these slight
differences in the variant bottle and
the effect on whether something is
called as a pass or a fail so the point
here being is that as the sequencing
technology evolves as your protocols
evolve you know the model that you have
right now for calling of variants in
whatever setting might not necessarily
be the right variant calling model for
what you would need on a new technology
or a new type of experiment and the
ability to retrain that and to do all of
the validation very quickly and to
understand what's going on very quickly
and expensively is hugely valuable
because when you're doing things in this
clinical setting you have to be able to
go through that validation cycle quickly
so you can ensure that you always have
the latest and greatest technology but
it's also up to the high standards of
the work that you want to do when you're
returning data to patients the last
example I'll give of just being able to
do this R and B it scales again using
these pileup GBCs you know we looked in
the emerge panel across 16,000
individuals for sites that might look
like they might be a mosaic type variant
where they have allele ratios that are
outside of the normal expected point
five so we did some filtering and you
know profile different variants of how
they looked across the whole population
to identify putative sites where this
might be occurring but again the very
useful thing here is that because we
could rapidly adjust our variant caller
and make these pileup GBCs we were able
to actually make a mosaics tensive
project level VCF in you know just a
couple of hours using a 32 core instance
again using geo maxes so again the idea
here is that when we're trying to
prevent heterogeneity we're trying to
assess heterogeneity having these very
rapid scalable tools at your disposal
gives you the flexibility to do the
innovation you need and then the ability
to rapidly go through the validation
that you need for the clinical settings
so it's really marrying the research and
the clinical sort of mantras that we
need you know to move forward in the
precision medicine so moving outside of
small variants thinking about how
heterogeneity you know this
moving away from preventing
heterogeneity and assessing
heterogeneity - how do we correct or
adjust for heterogeneity and this is
starting to get into structural variant
calling you know large complex variation
and just to go through this and I
apologize that this is basic for
everyone but the idea is that with
structural variants as opposed to small
variants the unit of observation the
read is smaller than the structural very
so you can't directly observe a
structural variant with a short read you
have to infer it from different types of
signal such as read depth split reads or
read pair discordance when paired reads
don't map in the orientation or the
distance that you'd expect because
structural variant methods are
inferential they're more sensitive to
heterogeneity things like coverage depth
the evenness of coverage how consistent
it is across the genome the length of
the read the insert size distribution
how close you expect the read pairs to
be and not just the you know the average
of that distribution but the higher
moments of that distribution as well and
also the read quality and this is sort
of the my example slide that if you
don't account for heterogeneity when
calling structural variance this is an
example of some work that we did 584
samples we call deletions we excluded
things that were specific to one of the
three protocols that were used and even
excluding protocol specific events we
see total segregation of the we see
total clustering by the protocol and
that includes these three replicates
that we had apparent and to daughters
but even though it's three individual
sequence three times of three different
protocols they cluster by where they are
where what protocol they were sequenced
under not the individual itself now this
is raw data there was no harmonization
there were different references but this
just goes to show that unless you're
accounting for this harmonization up
front you're aware of this you can have
very strong batch effects with
structural variation our approach to
addressing this is the Parliament -
structural variant discovery pipeline
something that we worked on over the you
know last several years partnering with
Nexxus for its you know design its
execution its testing and its deployment
excuse me the idea here is that because
structural variants are one thing and
they're sensitive to all these
heterogeneity s that different callers
are going to leverage the different
signals in different ways so different
structural variant colors are gonna have
different strengths and we want to
leverage the expertise of the field as
much as possible so they're different
colors might look at different types or
size regimes they might be more
sensitive or specific depending on what
they the goal of the caller is and they
have different compute requirements so
what we've worked on is a single
mechanism to fold all of these callers
into a single framework and this is a
docker that's available that takes in a
cram file runs multiple callers
integrates them and then assigns a
quality score based on the profile of
that call what we have found is that
multiple callers obviously they increase
discovery because the more callers you
run you can see more different types of
things but beyond that looking at the
combinations of callers saying okay well
what different callers were able to
support and give an event in a sample
that can also inform the quality of that
sample so the idea again behind
Parliament is that we run multiple
callers to leverage their strengths but
also to understand how they interact to
inform the quality or the confidence of
these individual calls and before I get
into more about the quality of these
calls and how we've leveraged this tool
at scale I do want to point out that
because of some very clever work
integrating bees in a single docker it
runs both on AWS Google Cloud we've done
extensive testing although obviously a
doctor can run anywhere but the point is
is that by putting these together an
appropriate way we can paralyze them and
get several methods for free
you know there's certain colors or
combinations of callers that we're going
to take a certain amount of time we
build the right instance on the cloud we
run the other callers in the background
we've also been able to throw in other
tools for other things such as small
variant calling and QC metrics but the
idea is that by putting all these
together into
framework you're running these much
faster and less expensively than you
would if we were running them
individually I also point out that while
the field makes the transition from
Bam's to crams if you had to run all of
these individually you know or in
different settings or you're trying to
combine from different places
everyone's doing that work of converting
to cram to a BAM a lot of the day that
we have now are in cram format so the
idea that you're pulling all these
together you're doing all the work in
one spot there's a lot of overhead
you're saving as well and that allows us
to execute this at scale but before we
scale up and really have to focus on how
well does it perform by itself on a
single sample and what we have looked at
is the genome in a bottle from the nist
organization they've created a high
confidence structural variant set on the
hg 0:02 sample so we've done the work of
taking a 30x sample short reads and
identifying how well not just the
parliament to method performance but how
every combination of callers performs in
terms of recall of these high confidence
events and one thing to point out is
that these high confidence events are
generated from extensive very deep
coverage and short reads long read data
orthogonal technologies so we swen we
see that the recall for all of these
caps out around 71% we have to keep in
mind that a lot of these events were
discovered by long reads so if we've
done analyses and you know if anyone has
questions or wants to follow up on this
profile but I'd really encourage
everyone to take a good look at the
genome in a bottle truth sets that that
team does great work and it's a it's a
hugely useful resource for everything we
do in the research in the clinical
community so what we see here is the
recall for different combinations and
you can see that as you start to get
three or four callers you really start
to plateau at about 71% of being able to
recall all the events and the truth set
including those that were detected by
long reads thinking about precision you
know looking at the different callers
and seeing what combinations give you
the fewest false positives
we these again are based on the h0 to
truth set and what was done here is
using as we use these precision values
these precision values to assign a
quality score to every call that
Parliament to makes based on the type of
that call and the combination of callers
supporting it so again it's not just
that multiple callers increase our
discovery power it's also that they help
inform the quality of a given call
before I go into some of these more
scaled results this is a this method has
been applied Parliament to to all the
thousand genomes that about 2600 low
coverage thousand genome whole genomes
before we apply Parliament to we did
remap these 238 with the NIH
functionally equivalent protocol these
calls are available if you go to the
preprint of the parliament to paper and
bio archive you can find access to these
and the best of my knowledge this is the
first time that a consistent espy call
set unclear d8 has been done for the
thousand genomes project but even if
it's not it's a great research that's
totally harmonized and those are
available to the community and just like
we did with small variants thinking
about how do we think about QC and
harmonizing one of the things we did
with structural variants in parliament
to was to look at concordance between
the Novus seek and the high seek
platform and the the relative value of
the quality scores and we had five
replicates or nova seeks one high steep
we did it 35 and 50 x coverage and we
sort of did filtered and unfiltered
unfiltered was just taking all the raw
calls out of parliament ignoring the
precision based quality scores and then
filtered was using only those events
with a quality score of greater than
three and what we can observe here at
the top is that the replicate
concordance for both nova stick versus
nova speak and notice think versus
high-speed when you're not using any
sort of quality scores that concordance
is lower and it's very disparate between
the two types of comparisons when you do
apply these quality scores that can that
replicate concordance goes up and it
also be
closer so we're not just improving the
quality of the calls we're also starting
to remove some of the batch effects
between platforms that we could observe
so that's a double win for us that we
you know we're getting more confident
calls and those confident calls are less
suspect and you know what platform the
data will run on which is really
important because as we start shifting
to the Nova sneak as a field we don't
want to ignore all the highest eek data
we have to be able to embrace that
heterogeneity and just accept the fact
that our methods are gonna have to adapt
we can't do anything about the raw data
itself and that and that was sort of our
single sample with a high confidence
that that we looked at to look at the
high state versus the Nova seek we also
did this at scale obviously we don't
have we don't have replicates done at
the same location for hundreds of
samples what we do have is matched
samples and what we did was take three
hundred and three high seek and three
hundred three nova seek and prosecutor
try to match them in terms of ethnicity
gender coverage insert everything and
then we ran Parliament on this to
identify whether there would be batch
effects and sure enough that if you do
the principal component analysis you do
see separation by platform in each of
the ethnicities which is you know
perhaps unsurprising given that you know
the Nova state does have a different
profile in terms of you know the
evenness of coverage especially in
certain regions however after we apply
filtering to these stats we can see that
these differences go away so we can see
that the filtering is appropriate not
just at a single sample level but also
across different ethnicities at a larger
scale that's a lot of talking about how
we QC and how we do the methods which is
all really important because we don't
want to jump into actually generating
these data until we have an
understanding on how we can do so
correct and the latest example where
we're at right now is our cardiovascular
disease freeze - structural variant
summary this is a multi-ethnic
population which is described at the
bottom right we just found identified
over ten million structural variants
broken down described at the top with
about about half of them being
Singleton's which is consistent with
what we see a large
snip sets as well and I'll go into some
of these results here about how we did
this but I would like to point out that
you know we were able to generate these
structural variant results executing at
scale and just about 12 days and the
bottleneck there was really just a job
limit so we didn't you know break AWS or
any of the other systems but we
processed almost a petabyte of crams and
2.3 million core hours then just under
two weeks this type of scale work is
possible it is reasonable you can do
whole genome structural variant calling
at reasonable prices and we should just
make sure that everyone's on the same
page that these things are feasible and
they're becoming increasingly more
common and that's just gonna open up a
lot more data to the field but when we
generated these results with Parliament
we didn't stop at single sample calling
and filtering we before we got into the
genotype phenotype analysis there's not
actually a poster I just didn't crack
that slide but this is work done by
Guzman at UT School of Public Health
what we did was take these structural
variant calls and analyze them compared
to cardiovascular phenotypes but before
we did that analysis we did do some
joint genotyping with nu C and B and
this is software that takes the calls
that we identify in Parliament profiles
all of those positions across the crams
for read-depth and paired end signals
and then it weights those signals by the
extent of multi method support the idea
being if there's a rare allele somewhere
that we might be interested in
but that rare allele because we're not
seeing it many times in many samples but
if it is supported by multiple programs
will equate that allele so that state
knows more likely to be picked up as a
real event so again we're not just
increasing discovery running multiple
methods we're also improving the type of
data we have to improve things like
joint genotyping so what do we do with
this joint genotype set we compared it
to risk factors and quantitative
quantitative traits across
cardiovascular disease interesting
phenotypes so all of these were compared
and
what we were able to identify or
associations again this is just a
structural variance set against
cardiovascular disease phenotypes so we
observe some novel deletions that are
associated with these different genes
are clinical markers and what we've
noticed was that being as we look at
these different ethnicities we can see
that some of these deletions and
different events have different effects
in different ethnicities so again this
is the idea that we want to make the
work that we do relevant to every
individual every ethnicity but again
every type of bearing right if you have
a structural variant we want to make
sure that we're doing the type of
research that's going to drive that the
research that will allow that variant to
be actionable for your personalized
health so everything that I've sort of
described here is what I call better
practices I'm always reluctant to say
anything as best practices because we're
doing things at you know unprecedented
large scale all the time and the idea
that there's one best way to do it we
just don't know what we're doing this as
we go and that's why the Rd at scale is
so important so critical but these
methods have proven successful at scale
they're all publicly available and you
know I'm always happy to answer
questions or you know if anyone wants to
reach out about how we've done this
we're more than happy to share so now
that we've talked about comprehensive
genomics and this idea of how do we
really look across the whole genome to
find all of the variation and do this at
scale so it's relevant get back to this
idea of you know how do we drive that
comprehensive genomics back to the end
of one personalized medicine again how
do we make what we do relevant for every
individual carrying any type of variant
with any type of phenotype we really
have to think of the full spectrum of
genomic scenarios that an individual can
be in when they're looking for genomics
to help with their health so as we start
to think about the clinic you know I
think a lot about the sequencing
logistics and how we how do we manage
the most important thing when you're
a clinical setting which is the privacy
and respecting the the needs of the
patient or the participant this is
something that work led by many people
here at the center did with the emerge
Network where there's multiple clinical
partners and there's multiple sequencing
centers and the way that we built this
to really ensure that we were absolutely
moving forward in a way that is
appropriate for doing things in the
clinical setting is working with
DNAnexus creating a Pho repository using
their features where we would pull data
in to this thi repository which had all
of the compliance that you know was
necessary we did it the identification
there and then we pulled all of that
down into our local environment for
sequencing which was also had all of the
acronym compliance that you would want
we did a pH I join and push that back
out excuse me to our clinical partners
the idea here is that both environments
had the the appropriate security and
compliance but by limiting I sort of
boxing off certain steps you just sort
of even further limit any possibility of
things getting out you sort of can
separate these so anything on one end
doesn't impact things on the other end
and this workflow was totally novel and
emerge because it was really as far as I
know one of the first ones where this
had to be coordinating among multiple
clinical labs both working within the
same program so this type of
infrastructure that we built is really
what enables us to start operating at
the scale we need because you know
clinical right now there's a lot of sort
of hand-holding that has to be done or
first you know you can't have computers
do everything you need a lot of people
who are looking at variants interacting
with patients doing all of this human
work that's incredibly important and I'm
always thinking about how do we capture
as much of that as possible to take as
much of that time load off of physicians
and genetic counselors and patients and
everyone involved so they can focus on
the things that they're uniquely
qualified to do and one of the
innovations done by here at the HDS see
led by Eric Venter is the Neptune net
to bury an interpretation reporting
workflow the idea is that as you see
variants and you start to review them
you automate as much of the annotation
filtering as you can and when something
needs to be reviewed it's not just that
you pass that off for review is that
whatever is done in that review and
captured goes back into what we call the
VIP database and that then informs the
filtering such that the more variants
you see and the more you annotate the
fewer you have you won't have to do that
one again because the automation is
going to pick that up so presumably
we're only using the human time to do
the new things and we're automating
everything else and that's really going
to be the most critical part to scaling
a lot of these large programs I feel
like I'm running a little low on time so
I would probably move through the next
couple of these pretty quickly but this
is just an example from emerge about how
the number of cases that are the number
of samples that are sequence the mer
variants that are seeing how does that
translate to number of cases and this is
really something that we're thinking
about as we have to scale is that if we
want to do a million individuals and we
want to start looking outside of protein
coding regions or clinically you know
ACMG 59 as the number of variants that
we have to look at scales we absolutely
need to develop the automation and the
infrastructure to scale that as well you
know and it's not just limited to small
variants we've done a lot of work trying
to really get high accuracy single exon
resolution cnv calling and capture
designs and you know then also extending
this again to the whole genome so again
this is work we're going back to this
idea of QC because of the sequencing
strategies having a method that takes
advantage of normalization across
multiplex flow cells for example that's
what you can see in this this pre print
of the paper is really critical to being
able to move forward but there are
limitations to short reads only and one
of the things I've been thinking a lot
about lately is you know this idea of
should we do a panel and exome or a
genome there's also this component
should we be looking at short reads or
should we be looking at long reads
there's a lot of long read technologies
out there they obviously help in
structural variants across
regions or send dupes for small and any
type of variant they are you know they
do have some challenges associated with
them but this is just one example from
fritz here at the HP SC of an inversion
flanked by deletions where it's very
clearly an inversion flanked by two
heterozygous deletions in the long read
data and you know if anyone can look at
that short read data and tell me it's an
inversion flanked by two deletions
please give me a call I will hire you
but it's not just identifying structural
variants it is also this idea that
there's phasing that might be necessary
necessary this is an example of a gene T
P and the T where the phasing of two
variants that are eight thousand base
pairs apart impacts the classification
that you would then report out you're
never going to get that phasing with
short reads alone so this is just one
example of a situation where you know in
order to have full comprehensive
genomics you might not be able to get
there with just one technology and this
is again some data from fritz that shows
you know how long long read phasing
verses long range linked read phasing by
10x you know how you can get that
phasing by using again a different
technology and I think the takeaway is
that depending on the type of analysis
you want to do different combinations of
short reads long reads linked reads are
going to be the way to go you just have
to sort of balance that obviously with
the budget but the idea is that we're
moving toward a world where every genome
is a gold genome and all genomes are
done and are going to be clinical all
genomes that you sequence are going to
be relevant to personalized health and
we can get to the point where all of
them are very high-quality and we think
about how we can work towards these
whole genome upgrades taking all of
these points into account and one of
these models is thinking beyond a single
sample we have a pilot here at the HDS
see the idea being we've taken a lot of
short read whole genome data we've
processed that for structural variants
we've used those short read detected
structural variants to identify a subset
of samples that would be ideal
candidates for long-range sequencing and
then once we do the long-range
sequencing maybe identify or
characterizing com
Lexx alleles we can then what I'm
calling broadcast those long reads back
into the short reads and genotype those
long read detected events with the short
read data because genotyping a known
event the short reads is a lot of user
than detecting it de novo so this idea
of you can combine different
technologies not just in one sample but
across large cohorts is another way that
we can really drive this idea of
comprehensive genomics and get the most
out of the resources that we have this
is something that you know we're
absolutely thinking about as in all of
us genome sequencing center which is
going to be ramping to hundreds of
thousands of whole genomes over the next
couple of years and it's not just doing
the sequencing which we know how to
scale that it's really thinking about
how do we scale that and do the
reporting and get these results back to
the participants of all of us in a
reasonable manner looking at whole
genome data for you know hundreds of
thousands of people so thinking about
that scaling and thinking about the
security you know this is the model that
we're sort of proposed of us we merge
that with the e merge model where we you
know we interact with the all of us
different groups than the coordinating
centers they handle the pH I intake but
we still do sort of this double D
identification as we work with our
partners that Johns Hopkins excuse me
the idea being here is that you know
every group is you know treating the
data in a way such that it is secure and
compliant and it's you know lends itself
to the automation and the high scale
throughput and this is you know
something that we're really excited
about and the the specific things that
we're driving and me all of us program
is you know thinking about fire
standards and how those deliverables are
really going to be sterilized across all
of the different groups but the thing
I'd like to point out is that none of
these projects that exist in isolation
I'm not going to go through every one of
these points but all of these projects
that we work on talk to each other you
know for example thinking about all of
the large-scale structural variant
calling you know we want to reconcile
that with the cnv calling in our panel
data and that's going to mean we need to
go ahead and pull some of the Clint
XM or captured data up onto the 38
reference and we're gonna leverage our
work from the CCD G on that functionally
equivalent protocol all of these things
interact this is the great thing for me
working at the sequencing center here in
Houston is that I get to have access to
all of these projects and really find
the synergy between them and use that to
drive again the better practices which
is you know what pulls us into this you
know clinical population space so with
that I do want to leave some time for
questions
this work is supported by many many
people in many many grants I've
highlighted the people who contributed
to the slides that I presented here
today these are all just a great team
especially our collaborators at DNAnexus
I really appreciate the opportunity to
speak today and I am happy to take any
questions thanking them for that
informative presentation we now have
time for questions and answers if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
to do so now just click on a Q&A button
at the bottom of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is what is
the minimal corps count you would
recommend for utilizing Parliament to on
large data so the we have optimized this
to run on 16 core machines both on GCP
and AWS and we have found that the disk
16 cores somewhere between around 60
gigs of ram and 200 to 400 gigs of disk
attached to that at solid state is the
appropriate for the speed that gives us
really good performance and you can
scale that disk as needed depending on
the size of your cram but we've played
around with that a lot the 16 core
really is the best balance of time and
cost great thanks yeah our second
question is yeah what are your plans for
scaling up with each additional year
with the all of us program right so
that's something that the
we were we talk with the program about
and they're doing such a fantastic job
enrolling people that we're really
excited to see that growth and I'll just
sort of put a pitch in anyone watching
this and anyone you know can go to all
of us there their website and sign up
and you know enroll right now it's just
it's just a completely open program the
scaling you know there's a combination
of whole genome sequencing and whole
genome arrays that are going to be done
I think the whole genome sequencing like
I said we're probably going to be doing
a couple thousand ten thousand the first
year and that's gonna ramp really
quickly with again the goal of having a
million sample sequenced in five years
so we're really expecting to be cranking
through many more than ten thousand the
next couple years great so it looks like
the timer just one more question
those who's questions we haven't had
time for we'll be following up with you
by email so we'll are there any tools
you would recommend outside of exit
lists and Parliament - yeah absolutely
you know there's a ton of really great
people working out there in so many
fields I would say that one that I
really like is Sam plot from Ryan layers
group for visualizing structural
variants that's been it's really just a
smooth program they've made some nice
moves lately on that also from Ryan
there's the he's working on the sticks
method which we really like I've really
liked working with the Illumina teams on
investigating their strelka variant
caller especially in the somatic space
and obviously working with the Edit code
teams on their methods
you know those FPGAs are really
interesting there's a lot of different
and then all of the constituent programs
in Parliament all have great strengths
and great development teams behind them
I know it's it people like to be able
just pull something off the shelf and
run it and that's what I hope we created
with Parliament but if anyone has the
interest in wherewithal you really
should explore a lot of these spaces and
some of these tools that I've just
mentioned you know are really a great
way to you know get your hands on some
data and figure out what works best for
your
all right great well I'd like to thank
once again will Salerno for his
presentation do you have any final
comments well no I just like to
encourage people to follow up with any
other questions as there's more time
engaging the community like this is how
we drive the research necessary to do
what we're doing and I'm really grateful
for the opportunity to both DNAnexus
and the group that put this on Thanks
all right thank you and if you're
interested in learning how DNAnexus
provides a scalable cloud environment
for clinical data science exploration
analysis and discovery please email info
at DNAnexus comm or visit DNAnexus comm
for more information before we go I want
to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing for six months from today's live
event you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
is available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye